bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale
on commence avec les titres le crédit
agricole d'île de france visé dans une
affaire de blanchiment d'argent une
plainte contre x vient d'être déposé des
agences yvelinois elles sont accusées
d'avoir fermé les yeux des comptes
personnels auraient été utilisés comme
des comptes professionnels plus
d'explications dans un instant la
voiture c3 ne sera plus produite sur le
site psa de poissy le groupe
délocalisent la production en slovaquie
une annonce qui inquiète les syndicats
un accord a été trouvé entre la
direction de fébus et les syndicats une
grève entamée le 12 mai perturbait
fortement le trafic des bus sur
versailles retour à la normale prévu
lundi prochain
et puis nous retrouverons amara traoré
bonjour vous êtes con fondateur de
l'association very emploi son but aider
les jeunes à entrer sur le marché du
travail
on en parle dans un instant mais avant
cela place à l'actualité économique de
la semaine
les chiffres du chômage viennent de
tomber ce soir en ile de france le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi en
catégorie à s'établit à 637 me l'a 6
empreinte ce nombre augmente de 0,1 pour
cent par rapport au mois dernier
concernant les yvelines ce taux augmente
de 0,7 pour cent le crédit agricole
d'ile-de-france impliqué dans une
affaire de blanchiment d'argent
une plainte contre x a été déposée cette
semaine et c'est clairement cette bande
banque équipe attaquer à l'origine
d'informations judiciaires datant de
mars 2013 impliquant six personnes pour
escroquerie et recel en bande organisée
c'est en vide dit vie du aurait
illégalement revendu des camions les
sommes perçues
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
ont été déposés dans des agences
yvelinoise du crédit agricole
la direction aurait alerté les autorités
qu après presque deux ans de mouvements
de capitaux
parmi les six personnes mises en examen
deux ont été écroués pour leur avocat
claude deboosère halle qui dit il estime
que la banque et complice et à profiter
de faire fructifier cet argent on écoute
le comportement de professionnels qui
laisse fonctionner des comptes
personnels qui lors de l'ouverture alors
qu'ils savent pertinemment notre
connaissance de cause que la seule
revenus déclarés sont des revenus de rsa
alors qu'ils ont admis des somme très
conséquente et qu'ils ont vu évoluer un
conte comme un véritable compte
professionnel
eh bien ces gens là ils peuvent pas être
écartés des poursuites il faut qu'il se
justifie c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai déposé plainte contre x
pourquoi parce que ça vise plusieurs
faits ça peut constituer des agissements
de blanchiment d'argent et donc par
conséquent le crédit agricole n'est pas
à l'abri des poursuites
il devra se justifier sur le plan local
mais sur le plan aussi la direction le
crédit agricole de son côté n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande d'interview
psa peugeot citroën va délocaliser la
production de la prochaine génération de
la citadine c3 en slovaquie elle est
actuellement produite sur le site de
poissy des sources syndicales et évoque
également la délocalisation d'une autre
voiture
l'entré deux
un de la 208 la cgt craint de nouvelles
suppressions d'emplois
on compte actuellement cinq mille huit
cents personnes ont cédé sur ce site
yvelinois la circulation des bus à
versailles devrait reprendre normalement
lundi prochain un dialogue a pu être
établi entre la direction et les
syndicats pour mettre fin à la grève
entamée le 12 mai les grévistes avaient
dans un premier temps bloqué le dépôt de
bus et la circulation était encore
jusqu'à aujourd'hui très ralenti hier
les syndicats ont obtenu une hausse des
salaires de 1,2 pour cent une prime de
fin d'année de 360 euros une prime de
participation exceptionnelle de 240
euros a également été versé à tous les
salariés
c'est justement la baisse de cette prime
qui avait mis le feu aux poudres
cette année les syndicats agricoles ont
fait parler d'eux on se souvient
notamment du blocus de paris en novembre
dernier que vous pouvez voir sur ces
images
à l'époque les agriculteurs exprimer un
ras-le-bol d'une sur fiscalisation il
dénoncé une hausse de la tva les
nouvelles réglementations
environnementales ou encore des
contraintes réglementaires plus
importantes
à l'initiative de ce mouvement la fdsea
la fédération départementale des
syndicats d'exploitants agricoles d'île
de france
hier elle tenait son assemblée générale
à louveciennes et a dressé le bilan de
ses actions selon elle le blocus a
permis un assouplissement de la nouvelle
pac la politique agricole commune mais
il reste encore des efforts à faire
les questions environnementales limite
selon elle la production des
agriculteurs
on écoute damien greffin le président de
la fédération on va nous interdire de
traiter des plantes en fleurs pendant la
période de floraison
on va nous interdire de traiter à
proximité des habitations vous avez
entendu ségolène royal qui qui disait
hier qu'on allait interdire les
agriculteurs de traiter à moins de 200
mètres des écoles
donc voilà on est dans du dogme qui dit
moins de production mehdi moindres
revenus etc
mehdi moins de production aussi à
l'export donc on est véritablement dans
un système des croissants alors que en
période de crise on devrait plutôt
essayer de compter sur ce qu'ils font
qui fonctionne qui marque ce qui
rapporte des devises à l'état tous les
ans
vingt équipes universitaires en
provenance de sept pays pour un concept
de maison solaire autonome en énergie
c'est le principe du solar decathlon qui
s'ouvrira à versailles le 28 juin la
compétition lancée voici dix ans par les
etats-unis se déroulera donc en france
pour les sociétés hexagonales c'est
l'occasion de dénicher de nouvelles
idées et d'exposer leur savoir faire
erdf vient d'acter son partenariat avec
la ville de versailles
elle va mettre à disposition un réseau
intelligent de distribution publique
d'électricité alimentant la zone de
compétition et des bornes de recharge
des véhicules électriques et on veut
vraiment à partir de cette opération
tirer des enseignements sur la manière
optimale de gérer des réseaux de
distribution demain avec l'ensemble des
nouvelles technologies mais surtout avec
l'intégration des énergies renouvelables
et puis également avec des nouveaux
usages comme le véhicule électrique
mon texte un test donc grandeur nature
pour cette entreprise
à quoi ressemblera la voiture du futur
une association bretonne mise sur un
véhicule solaire une voiture écologique
qu'elle présentait mardi à satory sur le
bord de la piste patrick jacques de
dixmude un mickaël jarry et jérémy et
brassent des voitures de course
elle n'est pas la plus rapide mais elle
est de loin la plus écologique
équipé de panneaux solaires cette
voiture électrique convertit l'énergie
solaire en électricité pour pouvoir
avancer
elle peut rouler jusqu'à 80 km/heure et
la piloter provoque des sensations aussi
forte que dans les autres véhicules de
course
on est au milieu de la voiture au ras du
sol
or on monte facilement à 70 80 km heure
donc les sensations évidemment sont
extraordinaires et qui dit voiture
écologique dit conduite écologique née
beaucoup plus se disent ont impliqué
dans la conduite de la voiture sachant
que la conduite d'une voiture électrique
solaire
c'est une conduite souple
tout en douceur raisonnable disons c'est
une conduite durable initiée en 2009
ce projet de voiture solaire est
l'oeuvre de l'association eco solar
breiz derrière ce petit véhicule
de nombreux acteurs et plus de vingt
mille heures de travail aujourd'hui
c'est un peu plus d'une cinquantaine de
partenaires tpe pme des grands groupes
également et puis des laboratoires parce
qu'en fait c'est un mixte entre des
universités des écoles d'ingénieurs des
lycées car l'objectif du projet est
aussi de sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'écologie
au total ce véhicule solaire a coûté un
peu plus de 150000 euros
un investissement conséquent qui a le
mérite d'épargner les dépenses en
carburant et surtout de préfigurer la
voiture de demain
ce défi il vient d'acquérir un immeuble
de bureaux à montigny le bretonneux
coût de l'opération 32 millions d'euros
c'est ensemble construit en 2008 d'une
surface de 10 mille mètres carrés de
bureaux propose un restaurant
interentreprises et bénéficie 267 places
de parking l'actif est entièrement loué
au groupe hertz et assystem
il peut accueillir 900 salariés lusine
l'oréal de rambouillet appelé fabre ogi
a reçu la semaine dernière le prix de
l'excellence industrielle pardon par le
journal l' usine nouvelle et l'école de
management insead c'est dans cette usine
que le groupe de cosmétiques a imaginé
et tester la plupart des projets
d'amélioration de la productivité
déployés par la suite dans l'ensemble de
ses sites internationaux
sa particularité sa spécialisation elle
ne produit que des shampoings et d après
shampooing cela lui a permis
d'accueillir dans ses locaux son
principal fournisseur de bouteilles on
parle alors d'organisation walktall
autre révolution des chariots élévateurs
à guidage auto automatique qui prennent
en charge les opérations logistiques et
enfin le site investi dans une chaudière
biomasse en juin dernier les émissions
de co2 ont ainsi été réduits de 80%
on passe maintenant à l'entretien
et nous recevons sur notre plateau amara
traoré vont soir vous êtes co fondateur
de l'association very emploi alors tout
simplement expliquer notre action
écoutez action va consister à essayer de
rapprocher tout ce qui concerne l'emploi
les chefs d'entreprise
d'un autre côté les demandeurs d'emploi
j'insiste sur le fait que sur la
verrière on a notamment sur le quartier
du bois de l'étang une forte population
sans qualification sans formation et
pour répondre à cette demande forte
nous souhaitons c'est en cours de
discussion faire de la mise en place du
tutorat avec les entreprises locales
alors là on va revenir et vous permet
ces actions finalement cette idée allez
venez commence mais ce que vous êtes
vous-même verrière loi c'est lé oui
puisque je suis mêlé moi-même verrière
roi et c'est aussi sonia moussavi et
karima koubbi qui ont été aussi
mobilisés à travers la terre l'autre
confondateur et puis ensemble on a
souhaité poursuivre cette dynamique en
faveur de l'emploi c'est parti d'un
forum qui a eu lieu au mois de septembre
salle 2 du scarabée et puis à la suite
de ce forum civil à l'issue de ce forum
on a eu quand même 150 jeunes qui ont
participé et
donc voilà naturellement on a souhaité
poursuivre cette démarche alors il
existe de nombreux organismes déjà
d'elle bien sûr à l'emploi finalement
c'est un de plus
qu'est ce que vous allez apporter alors
ce qu'on souhaite nous c'est pas ceux ci
se substituer mais c'est optimiser les
moyens existants je pense notamment pour
l'emploi souhaité être partenaire de
pôle emploi aussi avec les entreprises
locales comme je vous le disais la mise
en place de tutorat ce qui permettra un
rapprochement entre les d'un côté les
personnes demandeurs d'emploi et de
l'autre côté chefs d'entreprise et des
partenariats qu'ils sont déjà là en
cours de création qui sont qui sont
voilà rien et aucune convention des
signes et si en cours de discussion donc
voilà vous avez lancé l'association
c'est vendredi dernier à vendredi
dernier elle et les premières démarches
souvent comme à celle là en joie vous
allez notamment ouvrir des permanences
ouvre ou cela et décalé l'univers
d'accord donc la première permanence se
déroulera le 20 juin le vendredi à la
maison de quartier du gol des temps
pourquoi celle du bois des temps parce
que dans nos trois quartiers comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est au
bois de l'étang où on a le plus fort
taux de chômage je peux pas vous citer
de chiffres concrètement et donc voilà
on souhaite vraiment ces permanences et
devront répondre aux attentes exprimées
des habitants pour les habitants
d'aléria nous habitons de la verrière
dans un premier temps et puis
à terme si ça marche bien les autres
pourront venir et je voudrais aussi
ajouter que je les jetais j'ai oublié de
mentionner homps répond proposera
également des séances de coaching bat de
préparer un entretien en coaching savoir
est en entreprise et ce qui sera
intéressant c'est que on va essayer de
capter auprès de ces jeunes loin de
l'emploi essayer de qui se redonne
confiance même les séances de coaching
peuvent être un bon moyen et je pense
aussi que sur un cv lorsqu'un chef
d'entreprise verra que intel a été
chômeur pendant à peu près un an mais
qui a été quand même qui a suivi des
séances de coaching
voilà on verra bien que derrière il ya
un travail que la personne veut est-ce
que vous soyez également offert c'est
finalement aller vers ces jeunes aller
les chercher maison et les guider vers
l'idée vers les chemins de jure qui a
aidé jean cécillon donc voit très bien
du coup les les actions donc ça sera
avec des entreprises pour trouver ces
jeunes ça sera la permanence vous allez
laisser aller c'est un oui j'en terrains
illégalement sur un terrain mais je
pense que la permanence il faudra
vraiment et on l'a développée mais sera
pas uniquement sur le cas tu vois les
temps on ira aussi à la maison de
quartier de l'île par kiss each pris par
et pour le village on a su que la suède
ou du scarabée qui peut être un bon
moyen je pense alors parmi les
confondateurs je crois nous ne vous même
pas connu de difficulté finalement
rentré savoir s'il sera une non moi
c'est vrai que
j'ai eu un parcours un peu atypique ou
classique
j'ai fait un sap et cuisine en deux ans
et puis j'ai été embauché par la suite
donc j'ai jamais j'ai jamais connu de
chômage puisqu'à présent même façon on
pourra les autres membres oui pour les
ottomans aussi ses ingénieurs j'apprends
ses souvenirs et une étudiante ruquier
carrément c'est ça du coup quand on est
étudiant est ce qu'on peut également
finalement l aider à rentrer sur le
marché du travail alors que nous même
pas encore rentrée bah ça peut être un
jeu oui je pense que c'est pas ce pas
contradictoire parce que souvent les
étudiants pendant leurs périodes de
vacances cherche un stage une formation
pour changer de filière je sais pas donc
je pense que ça peut ça peut être une
bonne chose également les personnes
intéressées on peut donc du coup envoyé
un mail à l'adresse à maurice et à
l'écran verrier emplois aidés mail.com
c'est ça je voulais juste rajouter un
autre une autre chose c'est aussi le
fonds d aide des entreprises qui sera
débloqué pour les verriers roi alors se
fondait des initiatives de la ville
nommé very emploi sera partenaire
voilà donc ça sera des aides financières
pour la permettront de donner un coup de
pouce à des jeunes qui ont un projet
qu'ils soient professionnels ont monté
une entreprise
je pense une formation ont fait appel en
tout cas aux porteurs de projets et qui
n'hésite pas à aller vers vous merci
beaucoup au soutien bienvenu sur notre
plateau comment on passe tout de suite
au magazine créé son entreprise en
famille une véritable aventure qu'a mené
la famille d euros à voisins le
bretonneux
caroline a ouvert son salon de coiffure
la semaine dernière avec l'aide de ses
parents des images de jonathan willeman
et patrick jacques de dixmude le
quartier de la grande île à voisins
accueillent depuis une semaine un
nouveau salon de coiffure cette création
d'entreprise est une véritable aventure
familiale
caroline est coiffeuse son père philippe
a quitté l'armée pour devenir le gérant
de la société
sa mère patricia arrêter son activité
d'assistant dentaire pour travailler à
mi-temps au salon que vous installez
juste là après cinq ans comme salarié
caroline avait envie de gérer son propre
salon mais à seulement 27 ans difficile
de convaincre les banques de financer
son projet par moi même ou
financièrement je n'aurais pas pu tout
seul complètement donc c'est vrai que
grâce à mes parents j'ai pu en fait
voler un peu de mes propres ailes
tout en ayant quand même la famille avec
moi son père a financé la cession de
droit au bail de son local et s'est
chargé des travaux
sa mère tient lieu d'assistante elle
gère notamment l'accueil y apprend sur
le tas les gestes de base
et puis va je fais aussi donc le travail
d'une apprentie c'est à dire que je
passe aussi une balle et j'enlève les
cheveux par perdre
le but est que notre salon reste le plus
le plus sympa aussi de plus
moi je suis dans les machines je fais
aussi le mon petit travail de maman de
la fia les clients semblent apprécier
cette ambiance familiale qui étrille est
d'ailleurs venu sur les conseils de sa
mère je trouve que du coup d'accueil
c'est vrai que c'est sympa de voir tout
le monde comme ça que y arriver cette
fois ci c'est vrai ça donne une bonne
ambiance en fait du coup ça non on se
sent bien que caroline n'est pas fille
unique alors il a tout d'abord fallu que
son frère et ses deux soeurs accepte ce
projet dans un premier temps de la soeur
et mes bons très vite quand même ses
records fur à mesure des discussions
familiales bas dans l'idée que c'était
finalement un plus pour tous d'avoir le
sentiment que tout le monde pouvait d
une des soeurs aujourd'hui toute la
famille se montre très mobilisés anne
sophie et philippines ont aidé aux
travaux et à la décoration
car le thème marin du salon est aussi
une histoire de famille on a invité en
bretagne pendant six ans et mon papa est
dans la était dans la marine donc du
coup c'est un petit clin d'oeil toujours
pour la marine pour la bretagne
pour financer ce projet philippe a
profité d'une aide de l'armée pour nous
encourager et les défis sont des
effectifs à partir de qu'une aide à la
reconversion il mais si c'était de la
reconversion peut être utile pour aider
des jeunes à se lancer
c'est où c'est parti comme ça cet ancien
commissaire de la marine a dépensé près
de 68 euros
rapidement patricia voulu prendre part à
l'aventuré elle aussi souhaité se
reconvertir mon but c'était surtout de
garder un emploi à temps partiel pas
avoir un temps plein et dans le domaine
de la coiffure aux proches de caroline à
prendre d'autres choses donc c'était
voilà c'était motivant aussi de
découvrir d'autres d'autres choses mais
travailler en famille n'est pas toujours
évident bah ça fait un petit peu étrange
parce que du coup on voit la journée le
week-end
mais c'est sympa parce que du coup le
contact se fait plus facilement avec les
clients aussi
ils voient bien que c'est ma maman parce
que c'est pas évident de faire comme si
je la connaissais pas du coup du coup je
l'appelle maman retravaille sa soeur
estime qu'il faut prendre en compte les
aspects positifs mais aussi négatifs
d'une entreprise familiale
je suis assez quand même partagé je
pense que c'est à double tranchant je
pense que ça peut apporter un plus mais
il faut bien s'entendre parce que parce
qu'il est quand même bien
forcément des années à travailler
ensemble et il faut arriver à passer les
problèmes ensemble sans se disputer sans
que ça pas non plus trop partie bas pour
ceux qui en font pas partie ni notamment
pour les trois autres frères et soeurs
qui travaillent pas là dedans ça prenne
pas trop de place sont plus dans la vie
de famille au quotidien quoi pour le
moment pas d'ombré au tableau la bonne
ambiance prime
philippe envisage même d'aider à nouveau
d'autres jeunes à se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat
et on finit l'émission avec l'agenda
mardi prochain déclic théâtre organise
un atelier pour mieux communiquer dans
ces entretiens de recrutement ou
d'évaluation en utilisant les techniques
du théâtre
rendez vous à la cité des métiers à
trappes de 14 heures à 16 heures 15 les
attentions
il vaut mieux s'inscrire et c'est la fin
de ce fil est qu merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine à 18h30